alright I finally get to see that one
movie about the big AI and the
superheroes that fight on is I feel like
I'm the last reviewer to see this movie
I swear to God
oh I bring it to you with sincerity
that's what matters right Avengers age
of Ultron so Avengers age of Ultron is
the second Avengers movie in the closing
chapter and what we call Marvel phase 2
and in this movie Ultron's an AI that
gets created by Tony Stark and is like
you know I think I'm just gonna screw
the human race because that's what an AI
is going to do in a movie like this what
do you think is gonna happen now only
the Avengers can stop it but at a more
monumental note The Avengers have a lot
to live up to in this movie I'm not
gonna lie to you for the first I would
say third of this movie I was
entertained but I felt like I've seen it
before that's a really hard thing these
Avengers movies are going to have to
overcome is the fact that the Avengers
happened we saw it happen and half the
greatness of it happening what's it
happening all the Avengers in one movie
there was a time that was just
impossible now it happened that was
three years ago now you can't rely on
that novelty now we have to step it up
we have to see something great and the
Avengers were doing cool things but I
was like I've seen it before
there's a really cool Throwdown between
Hulk Buster and Hulk but I was like the
wrecking a city I've seen that before in
spades before the crucifixion happens in
the comments section watch the video
till the end
but even among feeling like that first
credit goes to James Spader as Ultron
this is a sweet villain with a couple of
exceptions I felt like the villains and
Marvel phase two halos in comparison to
the villains and Marvel phase one Ultron
though man if you're gonna close the
chapter of Phase two you close it with a
bang this villains evil yes Raymond
Reddington is vernacular and general
persona so the stakes were high an age
of Ultron Ultron makes you feel like the
stakes are high it's just all bad news
all around what Ultron's going to do and
you need that a movie like this then it
happens something happens in this movie
where you're like or this is the coolest
thing that's happened yet and it flips
the entire mood of the movie to being a
deeper movie with deeper character
development then it holds that deeper
character tone all the way to the end of
the movie and it was great it was
exactly what the movie needed what are
the fears I had for age of Ultron was
the fact that they're introducing new
people you got Scarlet Witch you got
Quicksilver you got one other you know
he's in the movie right you know visions
and it's been an official vision poster
so I feel like it's
not a spoiler just alright visions here
I was really freaked out about vision
with a vision really really well better
than I could have thought they could
have done vision so I mean right there I
was like oh thank god honestly though
the last half of this movie stakes are
high you cannot let ultron when i like
it when a movie is like okay we cannot
let all tron do that thing we are going
to hold the line we will hold the line
and then boom the clash happens and
you're thoroughly entertained age of
ultron could have been an easy movie to
make even in the first third of the
movie where I was like yeah it's
entertaining I feel like I've seen it
before I was still enjoying it in that
popcorn fluff kind of way because it's
just easy to make an Avengers movie at
this point we're also on board with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that we're at
least gonna walk out going well I did
enjoy it at a point when the movie
focuses up and stops feeling like
they're setting up for the next Marvel
movies coming out and they go deeper
with the characters deeper with the
conflicts deeper with the emotion one is
the god by the end of this movie there
are two or three scenes where I was
tearing up was like oh my god this is
hitting me where I live man didn't
expect that from age of Ultron usually a
movie doesn't Wow me throughout where
I'm willing to be like okay that first
part we're gonna go ahead and chalk that
up to growing pains but this movie did
it it's great to see the crew back I
welcome the new crew with open arms I'm
going to be completely predictable right
now cuz I'm not an idiot I know this is
going to be a predictable thing but give
it a lot of thought there's no other way
to say vengers age of Ultron is awesome
tabular
you know why I unapologetically give it
that writing it's because of this
because I loved this movie and you
should never apologize for loving
something worth loving
right so Avengers age of Ultron have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more